what's a rookie mistake someone in their
20s can make with their money this is
from jonas
a 4k a rookie mistake that someone can
make in their 20s my answer would be
not understanding that you're going to
be 25 you're going to be 30 you're going
to be 35 you're going to be 40 like your
boy sauce here you're going to be 50 and
just blowing it all and going hard at
age 27 and thinking there's no tomorrow
it's a myopic view of life
you're going to be 25 you're going to be
30 save that money don't like you're
going to there's going to there's always
going to be time to party marcelo you're
in your 20s dave in your 20s how many i
mean how many of your friends are just
going ham yeah dude i mean sometimes
it's daddy's money you know what i mean
sometimes you can't you can't really
fight against that but uh yeah some
people are you know you're you're
chasing that clout baby there's a lot of
people chasing that clout right now
chasing that clown people chasing clouds
i agree i got a couple friends doing the
same thing some friends saving that
money yep other friends blowing them up
yeah so people think you know i want to
live my life and my 20s live my best
life because when i got old again dude
you're going to be 30 and that's still
young 40 still young people are living
100. we talked about social security
these people used to die at age 65.
my grandma's 90. she's doing great if
you enjoyed that short clip from the
sawzcast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]